[موسيقى]
تحت سماء البروفانس بالجنوب الفرنسي تقف
سلسله فونتو والجبليه شامخه عبر الزمن بين
الرهبه وتحقيق المتعه لروادها هذه مارات
شديده الانحدار فضاء لرحله اسطوريه من
سباق فرنسا للدراجات لكنها ايضا تمثل
تحديا للهواه صعود القمه على ثلاث مراحل
في يوم واحد قد يبدو ضربا من الجنون لكن
هناك من قرر فعل ذلك بكل المتعه
الممكنه الخامسه صباحا وعند سفح العملاق
الجبلي يستعد مغفي انجليزي هاو لركوب
الدراجات يستعد لرفع التحدي وخوض المغامره
لقد اشتريت فطائر الجوفر بالعسل التي
احبها من المتجر هي جيده فعلا لدي ايضا
بعض الحلوى من الحبوب في مثل هذا اليوم
ساسته لك بين 4000 و 5000 سعره
حراريه يرافقه في الرحله ابن لهذه المنطقه
جون ميشيل 67 عاما وله متجر خاص بالدراجات
الهوائيه بالقرب من الجبل يدرك قليلا نوع
هذه
المغامره صعود سلسله شيقه تستحق المغامره
لكن لا يمكن اعتبارها مجرد جوله او نزهه
بسيطه مع
الاصدقاء كيف الحال سيكون الطقس حارا
جدا سنتوجه يسارا ثمان ساعات من الجهد
سيقضيها الرجلان سريعا تكشف الطريق عن
سحرها وتظل القمه اسمى ما يصبو اليه
مارفين وجون ميشيل الذان تغمره سعاده
الطفوله الباكره يسيران على خطه طوافين
الكبار انه شرف كبير لي حين اشاهد فيما
بعد طواف فرنسا فارى الطريقه التي مررت
بها انها الخاصيه الكبرى التي تميز ركوب
الدراجات لدينا الحق في ممارسه هذه
الرياضه على نفس الارض المخصصه للمحترفين
المحترفون كما الهوات يدركون جيدا ان
سلسله فونتو اسطوريه وصعبه المراس تمتزج
فيها الانجازات والبطولات بالاحداث
الدراميه لا يمكنني الى ان اتوقف هنا قرب
س خلال سباق فرنسا للدراجات عام 67 سقط
الانجليزي تو سيمسون عند منحدرات سلسله
فونو ضحيه للحراره
[موسيقى]
والمنشطات
19n champion du
monde مع ذلك ظل فون فضاء مثاليا لتحقق
الفرنسيه مثل فوز يمون بوليد عام
1965 او فوز برنار تفني عام 72 طواف فرنسي
اسطوري يحلم جميع عشاق ركوب الدراجات
بالمشاركه فيه يوما ما بعد ساعين و3 دقيقه
من الصعود اقترب مارفين وجون ميشيل من
القمه للمره الاولى لكن هذا لا يمثل سوى
ثلث التحدي وبدايه هبوط مذهل بسرعه تزيد
عن 60 كترا في الساعه
لا باس الان من وقت قصير لالتقاط الانفاس
قليل من الماء للانطلاق مجددا في اثر
فونتو تستمر المغامره
مجددا يلتقيان
بدراجته انها رحله صعبه جدا بالنسبه لي لن
اقوم بها مجددا لقد كبرت في السن لو كنت
في ال لفعلتها ربما لكن الان لا
استطيع
تبلغ الحراره 30 درجه تقريبا والمسار شديد
الانحدار ينال التعب من جون
م بدات الحراره انه الجزء الذي اخشاه
بعدها سيسهل الامر لكن الوضع صعب
الان التشجيعات لا تغير من الامر شيئا
تحليا بالشجاعه لم يبقى الكثير للوصول الى
القمه في نهايه المرحله الثانيه من هذا
الصعود يتراجع
ميل الم شديد في
ساقي ما قمت به كاف لهذا
اليوم خيبه امل نعم تترين دائما خيبه امل
حين نسطر هدفا فلا نبلغه انا اسف لترك
مارفين لوحده في نهايه المرحله الثانيه من
التسلق لكنني اعلم انه لن يمانع ذلك يواصل
مارفين المشوار لوحده 56 كومت ضمن هذه
المرحله الثالثه خير من هذا التسلق
الاستثنائي معقده وتتطلب الكثير من الصبر
والتحمل العقلي العقل هو من يسير الساقين
اني اشعر بها تقول لي ما الذي تقترفه بحقي
لذلك كان من الافضل مواصله المشوار مع
الصديق جون ميشيل اني افتقده
قليلا بعد قطع 136 كيلومترا وصعود علو ما
يقرب من
4400 متر يحقق مارفينا الفوز الخارق كيف
حالك متعب
لكن المتعه فائقه ونحن نبحث عن اختراق
جميع الحدود وتخطي كل الصعاب من اجل بلوغ
الهدف لكن من الجميل دائما ان نتوقف عند
حد
ما في هذا اليوم يدرك مارفين انه لم يجتز
اي بطوله محترفه وان ما حققه من انجاز لا
يمثل سوى تحد بين الاصدقاء هل انهيت
السباق لم يكن
سباقا اهنئك على هذا الانجاز
مع ذلك كانت بحق واحده من القصص الصغيره
التي صنعت اسطوره عملاق الجنوب
الفرنسي